wow
[Music]
when I watch the sequence I love that I
still get emotional as he becomes the
fastest man alive
one of the things people don't realize
is that all the in-flight dialogue was
recorded in Flight you feel it in the
movie they're experiencing the g-forces
they're having trouble breathing it puts
you in the plane it's amazing
was we got to not only make a cool
sounding car but also treat it almost
like a beast
for the most part what you're hearing
there is actually a bottle rocket just
slowed down from being one second long
to being 60 seconds long and then me you
know on the sampler just kind of
manipulating it to give it the pitch
rise that I wanted it to have
those insane cause Clarity is King the
whole way of water is about a family
it's about an emotional Journey we were
trying to make sure that the story got
told in the most emotional and valuable
way
that's one of the Whirlwind of sound
because at this point in the film in the
1950s it was a frightening and dangerous
time for The Establishment because at
this point Elvis Presley shifted the
cultural landscape of America
[Music]
we go to all the extremes light and dark
loud and quiet brutality that doesn't
hold back
to the delicate moments of Devastation
all the emotions that the soldiers went
through in the story and in the war
foreign
[Music]